you have sent well wishes and donated to
help crystal sanchez after
eight news now shared her story the 30
year old woman is a police officer
she's a mother and a veteran who's
fighting cancer
the i-team's vanessa murphy has an
update on crystal's condition
and also an unexpected ceremony in her
hospital room
crystal sanchez married her fiance from
her hospital bed
as she fights terminal cancer for that
moment of time
she was extremely happy she got
something she wanted out of life which
was
very person she loved crystal and her
now husband cameron sims are both metro
police officers
captain dory corrin was crystal
supervisor who was helping to plan
a wedding but he says crystal's
condition is getting worse
the cancer started getting a lot more
aggressive unfortunately became
impossible
to do that wedding ceremony loved ones
say crystal's lung cancer was caused by
exposure to hazardous chemicals while
she served during the war in afghanistan
she enlisted to help pay for college and
after doctors told her
these are her final days her concern is
her daughter's education
fellow metro officers set up a gofundme
for crystal's care
and for six-year-old evelyn's college
fund crystal's biggest concern of course
like any mother any parent
was what's going to happen to her
daughter when she's gone while loved
ones show love
and support they hope for a miracle we
all know that in order for crystal to
survive what she's going through right
now it's going to take some
truly amazing
ability to defy the odds he points to
crystal's positivity and
gratitude both evident in this interview
from earlier this year i don't think the
word thank you even
covers it you know like i can't
just say thank you to these people
because it's so much more than that
vanessa murphy 8 news now
it's a strong lady right there we do
have a link to the gofundme account on
eight newsnow dot com
captain corian says loved ones were
trying to help crystal cross things off
her bucket list
but her condition and also copic 19
restrictions have gotten in the way of
that
if crystal's condition improves enough
for her to leave the hospital
they may plan a staycation